an ice
ball yeah the prophet said if you use
cold bu you get more reward you don't
want more reward BR that's not how it
works you don't actively go and find
cold waterin no please rewards extra
rewards what's wrong with you I want
extra rewards it's just m the six we
have helped 10,000 people learn how to
pray Salah like like me and for the
first time ever we are opening Salah
hubs in the UK and in Europe but we
don't have enough funds to do this long
term and perhaps the only reason Allah
has shown you this video because he
wants you to have the reward and to
increase your wealth because the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
charity does not decrease your wealth
help us teach people how to pray Salah
if your donation just helps one person
you get the reward every single time
they pray every F to is every day every
week every month every year their entire
lifetime and when they teach their kids
you also get that reward so click the
button or the link donate £100 or more
now remember we only need 1,000 people
to give1 to reach this target build your
that will continue even after you're
gone